listen now there's all there's so much
going on for you right now this movie
this is your directing debut yeah she's
got to be I would think the idea of
directing anything would would
intimidate and frighten me beyond belief
it must be a huge change for you it was
a huge change and and I was terrified
you know I've been I've been an actor
for so long there's certain things that
you kind of get used to as an actor and
being a director so different I mean I
was I'm going to work I remember and you
know just showed you how sometimes the
the more mundane things in life pop into
your head but I had all these people
that were waiting to hear what I was
gonna say you know about the camera
angles and you know the lighting and the
sets and all that kind of stuff and all
these extras and my first day at work
and all I kept thinking to myself is I
don't have to put makeup on no one's
touching your eyes you know no I think I
don't even you know it's like I mean all
day long with this I don't we don't have
a lot of people working on me I do it
myself in the bathroom let's go you know
it's it's a it's a it's a totally
totally different kind of experience me
I I I rapped one night we've been
shooting nights and I went into my
trailer and and as I've done a million
times before and I sat there and I I
started well that's not actually my
trailer was Kyra's trailer because I
didn't have a trailer that's right
you're directing your wife in the movie
yeah yeah they didn't give me a trailer
but so she let me use her as every once
in a while if she was you know feeling
generous and I I went in and I took off
my my my shirt you know and I took off
my shoes and I took my pants off and was
down wearing my underwear and I realized
these are my own clothes I don't have to
change I can take these home with me
directors they don't have to do that you
don't have to another perk for the
business no but you could be then on our
cable special yeah the best pretty
would you be all ready for it next on
Conan naked directly it's a great series
we'll be doing you know when in
preparation to coming on the show as
they do on a lot of these shows you
start doing research about your past
work and you've done so much so much
great stuff but one of the things we
found was this was this People magazine
cover
when Footloose came out I forgot how
huge Footloose was but take a look at
this shot there's you sitting there and
there's this and then there's this guy
there's this guy flipping all around
your picture and you sees all over the
place but it's not you I was like what
was what was the deal with that well
there's an interesting story with me you
know this movie it was a great movie and
I I was really blessed to have been
involved with it it was did great stuff
in my career but it's kind of it really
stood out haunted me you know and I was
I was so sick I was way too serious back
then mm-hmm and everywhere I went every
time I went anywhere everybody wanted me
to dance you know I mean this day I
can't go to a wedding or a bar mitzvah
or you know anything without the deejay
putting on the record and then people
you know form a circle around me and
starting like this and they sort of
expecting to start you know doing clips
like a trained dog I go to the DJ I
literally go to the DJ with $20 whenever
I walk into a club anywhere I say you
know I was a good guess what loosen this
hell yeah I got it right here you know
that's great record isn't it don't play
it okay hey it's 20 bucks people have
the gall to form a circle around you go
start shoving you like let's go it's
halfway always and and so you know when
the movie came out they wanted me to
dance on the cover of People magazine
and I was you know just way too serious
for that and I said I won't do it I so
the guy took some pictures sitting down
and I remember the photographer was
furious and he left room you know he
said I can't shoot this guy he won't
dance for me you know he won't do tricks
and stuff you know whatever he was mad
so they put this on the cover and they
and the guy who doubled me for some of
the gymnastic moves in a couple of the
dance moves they also put him on the
cover oh so they what they did is they
didn't tell you that they were gonna
have this guy floating all around your
head oh that was a little addition just
a few so you're surprised you pick up
your People magazine and then widen out
there more you can see this guy flipping
all
mocking you yes mocking yeah it even
says you know he Kevin Bacon you know
takes all the glory but the other guy
does all the work or sometimes that's
the wonderful business we've chosen well
you know